[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I've created quite the video
for you today about the attractive
genius momoyo zu from my hero academia
the last fact video I made was about to
you Asli aka FRA P and I wasn't sure if
I was gonna make another one but the
feedback was awesome you guys really
seemed to enjoy it and in that video I
asked who you wanted me to do next and a
lot of you voted for Momo
so Momo it is before we continue I want
to give a big THANK YOU to Elsword for
generously supporting this video Elsword
is a free-to-play MMORPG that puts you
into an anime inspired world where you
can pick from 12 unique playable
characters and let loose on the
environment or on other players using
epic skills fast paced sword combos
fiery explosions and more each character
has their own unique story and lore so
this is a lot more than just a mindless
action game and the setting kind of
reminds me of the I'm cried arc of Sao
or the fantasy world of kono Suba the
characters have their own unique
backstories job paths and skills that
you can choose from
there are frequent updates including
some very recent ones and there are
exciting events happening all the time
which give you the opportunity to earn
special rewards not to mention that they
recently introduced brand new character
artwork that looks extremely cool the
biggest reason I quit many of the
MMORPGs that I played in the past was
that they focus too much on pay to win
and you basically have to pay a ton of
money if you wanted to compete with
everyone else but what is amazing about
elsword
is that unlike other games this game is
transitioning from pay to win to play to
win which means you're gonna have fun
kick butt and stay competitive without
having to pay a ton of money to do it
check it out it's a great adventure and
I'm absolute blast to play link is in
the description and again it's totally
free to download and now back to the
video like always be sure to let me know
which character you'd like me to do a
fact video for in the comments or on our
Twitter and Instagram if you like these
types of videos
and want to keep them going then make
sure the united states of smash that
like button and don't complain about
your broken fingers or phone screens
because it was totally worth it also if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe for more MHA content and
texas smash that notification bell
alright alright alright now without
further ado let's get into ten facts you
probably didn't know about momo fact
number one
unlike frothy momo has never broken the
top ten most popular characters list
surprisingly in the first japanese poll
she got 11 and in the second one she got
13 and in the third and latest one she
got 14 in the shounen jump us popularity
poll she placed 12th and in the most
voted MHA popularity poll held by
crunchyroll in 2018 she ranked at her
highest which was 11th place after alien
Queen and before the manly hero read
riot back number 2 Momo is a rare kind
of super genius who in the official data
book got a remarkable off the charts
score of 6 out of 5 in intelligence to
put this in perspective
Decco and Todoroki only scored 4 out of
5 as far as I can tell she is the only
character who scored so high besides
Toshi nori yagi aka
all might who scored a completely insane
6 out of 5 in every category
even though Momo is a student she was
able to analyze the team battle where
deco and/or choco fought Bakugan and EDA
better than even all might could have
which catches him off-guard additionally
she was the number one recommended
student although Todoroki got in on
recommendations as well as did the
attack Titan from class 1b she was also
first in the quirk apprehension exams
first in class 1a is grades even taking
the time to tutor the students that were
struggling as far as we know she got the
highest mark during the hero license
exam a 94 ironically despite her insane
intelligence most confidence is
completely crushed after her quick
defeat by
mechag a in the top 16 round of the you
a sports festival and I mean quick it
got one small panel in the manga it
makes sense why this devastated her
because she is so smart and was the
number one student to get in our
recommendations there was an insane
amount of pressure on her the fact that
she comes from a prestigious hero family
doesn't help matters either
however she finally overcame her
shattered confidence during the final
exams arc where she and Todoroki became
the first to clear the final exams
because of her intelligence strategy to
capture eyes ala oh yeah and she is also
an expert at BO jutsu a martial art that
originally in japan that focuses on
using a staff in battle and for her
quirk needs to know the composition of
everything she creates I could go on but
I think you guys get the point she is a
one-of-a-kind genius fact number three
Momo's character design has undergone
some changes since horikoshi initially
sketched mobile for instance mol most
ponytail is more spiked than it was
originally and she definitely went up a
few bra sizes
additionally Momo's original hero
costume had a partial mask over her nose
kind of like frothy does but this was
removed in later versions the opening at
the front of the costume was also added
because it works better for her quirk
because more exposed skin means more
area to work with but this was
definitely done for fanservice reasons
as well and horikoshi is completely open
about his inner Mineta surprisingly Momo
actually wanted to leave even less to
the imagination but her costume was
revised for fear that her initial
costume would clash with the law it's
interesting that a character that is so
bothered by vulgarity is so comfortable
with exposing her skin although other
female characters have been censored in
different situations Momo is the only
character who was censored during the
usj arc after she shoots a huge
insulated sheet out of her back she
leaves her chest completely exposed in
the manga she is censored by a voice
bubble and in the anime by dust and she
seems completely comfortable being
exposed while judo definitely
doesn't feel comfortable but regardless
it's cool to know that Momo can actually
create objects from anywhere not only
from exposed parts of her body but even
under clothing although she will
probably tear the clothing if she does -
Mina does great pleasure fact number
four
I found this quite interesting the fact
that Momo names every part of her pro
hero outfit after her own name Yaya Zoo
which kind of reminds me of Joey from
friends we got that go on Monica's gonna
be here any minute
but it hurts my Joey's Apple anyways
rather than a leotard we have the excuse
my pronunciation
yow Yuri Attard which is the main part
of the costume specifically designed so
she can easily pop out what she creates
second instead of a belt we have the
Yaya belt which is thick so it can prop
up the third piece of equipment which is
a dictionary called you guessed it the
Yao your dictionary now I am most
fascinated by the dictionary which I
seem to have completely overlooked or
forgot about before learning about it
again while doing research for this
video this is pretty much a dictionary
of things that might come in handy for
heroics and the materials that are
involved for their creation the book
also has magnets on the cover and inside
pages so that the book doesn't fall out
during battle I gotta say as someone who
loves books I get a kick out of the fact
that she fights with one on her at all
times
however since she's so smart she has
committed the elements of certain things
to her memory and can create them
without referring to her book at all
fact number five Mullins quirk is
overpowered it is more overpowered than
it comes across in the anime when of
course she actually issued an apology to
the readers of Shonen Jump because he
messed up the explanation of her quirk
in a chapter he initially said that she
can create any substance if she knows
about it except organic substances but
in reality or should I say an anime
reality she can create anything except
living things so she could totally
create organic clothing or other organic
things although she only got a four out
of five and technique
her quirk has insane Opie potential
she takes the lipids or fats in her body
and can transmute them into the
materials she needs to create any
nonliving object this is beyond what
even a state Alchemist can do in the
show she creates more simplistic things
like a pole and shield and way more
complex things like cannons flashbang
grenades a tracking device a freaking
tracking device and implies that she
could even make night-vision goggles
someone on instagram asked if she could
make money and I would say that that
would be one of the easier things to
make but according to Momo that's
against the rules and she must ensure
that the economy runs smoothly
ironically Momo
is the last person in the world who
would actually need to create money
because she's insanely rich like your
whole house is probably the size of her
closet but besides money imagine
everything else Momo could make a
machine gun a motorcycle a bazooka an
atomic bomb a fighter jet theoretically
anything all she needs is the knowledge
behind how it's created I don't think
they'll explored these possibilities too
much in the show because she would be
way too Opie not to mention how
dangerous some of these weapons would be
to surrounding civilians but it's
undoubtedly one of the best works
especially when it's combined with a
supergenius user like Momo fact number 6
there's a reason that Momo's go-to thing
to create is a matryoshka doll aka a
Russian nesting doll in the manga there
was a special bonus page called The
Curious Case of yashka in which
horikoshi explains that Momo used these
dolls from a very early age as quick
training tools and she remembers them
fondly as the first ready-made product
she was able to create flawlessly now
she can pop them out one after the other
without sparing a thought that's just
how much she's practiced creating them
so Mo's decision to make much Ryoka
dolls in different situations is not
random there's a detailed story behind
it it is these kinds of little
background details which horikoshi
creates for his care
actors that really interest me and make
reading his manga all the more enjoyable
fact number seven
along with ITA's quark Momo's quark was
originally going to be a pro hero's
quark but then horikoshi thought that
such an elite ability like creation
would be more interesting to read about
if it were in the hands of a novice in
training it is interesting to also
consider that EDA and Momo might have
been Pro heroes because they do seem to
be the most responsible or adult-like
members of the class after all as
president and vice president of class 1a
they do hold the most responsibility
within the entire class I'm glad what it
cost changed his mind though about
making that pro heroes since we probably
wouldn't have seen Momo as often if that
were the case fact number 8 in the
original japanese dub momo is voiced by
a 33 year old marina in no way she also
voiced yoko lit nur from tengan Toppa
Gurren Lagann another well-developed
character and in attack on Titan she
voiced Armin alert so suddenly it makes
sense why ISA Yama said that Mika says
closest female friend was Armin fact
number 9 in the english dub momo is
voiced by the 38 year old colleen smith
Clinkenbeard love that last name by the
way she also voiced the future king of
pirates monkey d Luffy himself in the
one-piece Funimation dub and Risa
Hawkeye in Full Metal Alchemist bonus
fact she apparently also voiced a coffee
shop employee in steins gate the more
you know fact number 10 in lieu of one
final fact I'll do a lightning route of
random interesting facts about Momo here
Ready Set let's go momo always gets A's
even on blood tests she is the tallest
girl in class 1a at 173 centimeters or 5
foot 8 inches which means she is one
centimeter taller than Baku go her
birthday is on September 23rd so she's a
Libra like me in Latin ear Putin I was
also excited to learn that her main
hobby is reading books which made me
like her even more because I love
reading myself and that does it for the
final fact
round although I always like Momo I got
a say through doing the research and
making this video I've come to like Momo
even more than I did before so that's
pretty cool
next I asked you guys on Instagram what
your favorite thing about Momo is and
I'm glad to see that the post got 76
comments so obviously I'm not gonna be
able to feature them all but let's jump
into summary responses right now along
with others
shabooey feelings likes Momo's very
powerful quirk and I agree it's amazing
and opie as I've attempted to point out
ish 18 likes how compatible she is with
Todoroki and I feel like whoa Nikko she
would agree with you I mean look at them
they just make sense
Patrick Biddle writes that she is the
most opie hero what am I gonna do to an
unlimited supply of nukes good point sir
lastly MLA which sounds like the
Canadian version of the name Emily
comments that she is so genuine for a
rich girl and I also like that rather
than acting spoiled and like she's
better than others she genuinely cares
for others and wants to help and never
looks down on people
I'm glad the hoodie course she took that
direction with her character and that's
it for the comments thank you so much to
everyone who commented I'll do an
Instagram post like this for all the
upcoming fact videos so make sure to
jump on the instagram at anime uproar
and your comment could be featured next
time plus we regularly have great
conversations about MHA there and i
would love to hear from you I also want
to take a second to share this awesome
anime uproar fan art that Cuusoo mati
did for us in his free time make sure to
check out his YouTube and Instagram link
in the description and show him some
love this must have taken him a lot of
time and work I gotta say that we love
it when you guys send fan art of us or
our anime uproar avatar and if you wish
to make one we encourage you to send it
our way through Twitter or Instagram at
Anime uproar it could even be featured
in a future video once again thank you
coos Oh Mari so
yeah thanks so much for watching I hope
I did most awesome character justice
with this video and that you enjoyed it
takes to smash that like button if you
did and join the knock them up by
subscribing and hitting that
notification belt together we will
create an app for epic proportions
Pirate King style don't forget to let me
know what facts video you want to see
done next in the comments below
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you